so what is going to happen next with the
Kang
Dynasty welcome to sck your SciFi TV and
Movie
Channel I'm not very well so excuse me
doing a video in my pajamas like my
Christmas pajamas but I really wanted to
get this video out there because it's a
really interesting thing that happened
late last night so Jonathan Maes was
sacked by Disney following his guilty
verdict for those assault charges not a
massive surprise something I've spoken
to you guys about before was the fact
that Michael Waldren the guy that wrote
the um last two Loki series was asked to
rewrite Loki so that if they needed to
write out the Kang character that they
basically could the end of Loki season 2
gave them an out basically it meant that
because Loki had taken over and stepped
through that thing and like basically
tied all the times together and became
basically like a time God it actually
meant they could now in theory move away
from the K Dynasty as their future
serious villain because the timelines
are no longer actually at Major risk now
Michael Waldron is also now in charge of
writing a new script for The Avengers 5
now I'm calling it Avengers 5 because
that's what Marvel are now according to
my source is now also calling it they no
longer refer to it as Avengers the Kang
Dynasty internally it is now just the
Avengers 5 so what am I being told it's
happening well apparently Michael walren
is as I say currently working on a
script for that Avengers project and
they were hoping to start filming as
early
spring now for the last three or four
months Marvel have been planning for
this eventuality obviously like I said
they rewrote the end of Loki season too
because they basically assumed Jonathan
Maes was going down for these assault
charges they basically knew he was
guilty so they were planning ahead
immediately Loki season 2 was Rewritten
gave them an out as I say and plans for
what the Avengers 5 would look like if
that happened began now apparently they
currently have two options and Michael
Waldren is working on both of these
options for Avengers fight
one is that it will be a Kang dynasty
movie but it'll be very different it'll
be the final Kang film and Kang will
actually be a CGI version of the
character very much like what we saw in
um parts of quantum Mania but mainly
what we saw in the comic books so in
theory you don't nearly need Jonathan
mes if what you're doing is a CGI
villain that is one option the other
option is that they will cut the Kang
Dynasty now now apparently Loki season 2
did have and was specifically written
for the purpose of both of these options
and that it basically left a door open
for both of them so right now Disney are
thinking about the possibility of a
complete reboot of their plans for the
next 5 to 10 years now this is something
Disney and Marvel have already been
working on over the last 12 months or so
mainly because all of their movies
recently at least have bombed terribly
the Marvels actually recently was the
first Marvel movie pretty much done that
I didn't watch at the cinema couldn't be
bothered didn't go but Marvel have had a
problem for a while that even before the
Marvels which did badly a lot of their
films have been doing badly Doctor
Strange 2 even though it had good bits
in it was generally not very good and
the less said about Thor love and
thunder the better because that movie
was Bloody awful and creepy in places it
was really
creepy so Marvel obviously are reacting
to this and they were already making
plans to slow down their release
calendar to spend a little bit more time
on some of the movies they were planning
because that was one of the big problems
they've had recently is they were just
doing too much too fast and they
couldn't keep up with a lot of this CGI
Etc the guys doing the CGI are now
unionized by the way as well so you know
that's going to make even things more
difficult for
Marvel basically me they the some of the
CGI some of the films has been dodgy and
they realized that that was a major
problem moving forwards also a lot of
the TV schedule calendar has been slowed
down Disney have done the same with Star
Wars to be honest and again in reaction
to some of those projects not doing as
well as they'd
hoped so I'm being told by my my sources
that if they go with option one with
Kang and it'll just be the end of it
they will obviously use the excuse of
Jonathan Major's assault charges and
being being found guilty is the reason
for them doing that and they'll move on
to Bringing forwards a lot of the X-Men
villains Etc much quicker starting with
doom and then moving on towards bigger
characters like
Galactus or they will completely scrap
the Kang Dynasty
they will basically say that look Loki
is a fine ending to that it resolves and
ties off a lots of the knots we're done
they will again use the Jonathan mage's
excuse as to why they've done that and
they will as I say move on to the X-Men
and other villains way quicker than they
were originally planning to do now we're
going to be getting the Fantastic 4
we're going to be getting a lot more
X-Men Inc coming projects and movies
we've already started to see mutants
appear in the um projects we're seeing
at the moment so those plans were
already in place we're basically going
to see maybe two or three movies from
the story arc plan deleted and just at
story arc brought forward a little bit
those projects will though be done a
little bit slower from a calendar point
of view we won't be getting to or three
movies a year anymore we'll be getting
two at most basically I'm being told
that Marvel are looking at one major
movie and one sort of secondary movie
each year so there'll sort of be a big
project and then like something that's
just not as big and gr so we we'll get
an Avengers movie but then we wouldn't
get something like wakanda forever in
the same year for
example then they're really going to be
looking now I say that this Jonathan
major thing is going to be used as an
excuse and to be honest it's a good
excuse let's let's be fair and any act
to being done for those sort of charges
today is very difficult to carry on a
major
franchise but other actors have had very
serious allegations against him and
they've continued onwards it doesn't
actually look like jenan Mages is going
to have a very long prison sentence for
example it could be done why aren't they
because what Disney really want to do is
just have a massive reset they know
they've been going the wrong way they
desperately need to do this reset and
this Jonathan mes issue to be honest is
a nice excuse for them to use it gives
them a reason so that they don't
publicly have to say we're changing
everything because our movies have been
crap which is really the truth but guys
get to the comments what you think do
you agree with my source here that this
Jonathan major thing is a nice
distraction for Disney and Marvel and
actually their films have just been
awful and that's why they're doing this
massive reset that they've already
actually been doing and would you be
looking forward to Avengers 5 now it's
not going to be Kang because let's be
honest after Antman 3 do we really want
any more of Kang or if they do like we
said something that looks way more like
what we saw on the comic books would
that be exciting for me I'd actually
love to see that character done again
but done in a way that was more true to
what we saw in the comics in some of the
earlier comics in particular a way more
vicious violent villain rather than the
Jonathan maor's version which was a bit
I don't know soft and wimpy at times
guys get to the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out you never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
citre or most of our new videos Premiere
first and you can go to
c.c. which is our dedicated wee where we
do stories based on most of our videos
go check it out I'm going to go and get
a LM siip and I'll see you all
later